tu prêt oui je suis très
heureux de t'avoir connu spiderman quoi
comment ça dans quelques instants tout
le monde aura oublié que peter parker
spider man quoi tout le monde
on peut faire des exceptions sortilèges
ne fonctionne pas ainsi alors ma copine
va oublier tout ce qu'elle a vécu avec
moi mais après est-ce qu'elle sera
encore comme une enquête parfait
le monde entier va oublier que tuer
spider-man sauf ta petite amie c'est
super sympa merci de turini ok
maintenant on arrête de modifier les
paramètres de ce sortilège pendant que
je lance ok c'est bon c'est fini premier
site où j'arrête et ma tante mais il
faut qu'elle soit évident qu est ce que
tu pourrais arrêter
salut peter
ça lui en fait il vous connaît qu'est ce
que tu as fais ma machine votre
de quoi vous parlez de quelle machine a
envie de jouer avec
vous inquiétez pas madame jarret
[Musique]